[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i hope you enjoyed
your week i hope uh i thank you for
sharing
uh your time with with us here on the
podcast
ryan's here with me hello ryan how you
doing today i'm okay how are you doing
pretty good we had an early podcast this
morning we did and uh now we're gearing
up to do these uh
ads and things like that
so we can keep the show going i
appreciate everybody listening it means
a ton to me
uh also uh we're gonna be getting right
into billy magnussen here in a second
from no time to die the new bond movie
made for love on hbo many saints of
newark the guy's rocking it he was a
great interview i had a ball talking
with him
what a pleasurable just a good human
being yeah it's pretty cool and uh i
think you guys will really enjoy this
podcast um
shout out to all my patrons if you want
to help the podcast out a little more
there's a lot of perks and fun stuff and
uh that's patreon.com inside of you
p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon dot com slash
inside of you um also i'd love for you
to if you're here for billy to uh
subscribe to the podcast you can watch
it on youtube you can listen on stitcher
apple podcast and anywhere else you get
your podcast and what are our handles
ryan at inside if you pod on twitter
inside of you podcast on instagram and
facebook that's it uh it's very simple
and keep this podcast going i ask for
your uh your help your uh
your uh what's the word support support
would be the right word
um
really fun interview uh anything going
on here in the next weeks if i'll be at
the la comicon on december fourth and
fifth tom welly and i are doing a
smallville night so if you're in la you
might want to see that it's a really a
great little two-man show that we do and
we're gonna be signing autographs that
weekend at the la comicon so get your
tickets
get your tickets and uh
um also
uh november 20th november 20th we're
going to be doing a stage it my band sun
spin you go to sunspin.com
get tickets you can watch it virtually
we do two shows 2 pm 6 p.m pacific
standard time on saturday november 20th
and uh it is on the 20th isn't it isn't
that right
i hope so i i i i i would hope so i i
that's all i have to say
[ __ ] hell jeez ryan are you okay with
her it is it's the 20th uh [ __ ] it let's
just get right into it let's get into uh
this guy he's uh i'll let you uh let you
listen and let you decide i'm babbling
so i'm gonna get right into it let's get
inside of billy
magnussen it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience dude the first thing i want to
say is ryan here my engineer the first
thing he said was
he's got you have a podcast
who you oh i had it's uh my buddy put it
together uh kyle chevron and lamar
morris lamorne was on the podcast
lauren's a great guy lauren's a great
guy he's hilarious he's hilarious he hey
they wrote like a scripted podcast so
it's like a bunch of episodes and you're
on it yeah are you one of the hosts no
it's not like that it's scripted so
it's a story about like a it's a
throwback 80s action like comedy that's
uh just scripted out great donors just
but how did you get rick ashley to do
the music for it i don't know i don't
know you don't know my job that wasn't
my job you know who rick ashley is of
course i know i rick roll people all the
time never gonna give you off never
gonna let you down never gonna run
around and desert you all right now
you're a singer uh you do broadway i did
broadway but not um
not singing wise like that what those
people do eight days a week singing is
unbelievable i've done theater just like
live a lot of straight plays and stuff
like that i mean come on you you got
nominated for a tony luckily yeah it's
crazy such a weird weird thing again you
just kind of go through your career and
do what you do and
kind of [ __ ] just happens and stay
humble
at least i don't know how to do anything
else have you have you gone into any
[ __ ] phase because you're you're in
your 30s i mean have you gone into like
hey i'm [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] i'm like
cause i went and i'm sure those stages
were like hey all right and then you
realize hey shut the hell up there's
no i if probably my whole life has been
the [ __ ] stage you know
like all my jobs are like cast as like
the [ __ ] are you mostly cast as the
[ __ ] um i feel like i play the
villain a lot more than the the hero so
it's always i never would have thought
that i would have thought you were a
leading guy guy next door never never i
could see you playing dude
because he's jesus can you see the
jeffrey dahmer though thanks i really
appreciate well you kind of like have
his res a semblance to him a resemblance
i don't know what he looks like he's a
good looking dude i'll google him i mean
he's a serial killer yeah but yeah
that's not good that's not that's not
good
can i say something about you so
i don't know
look we never met each other before or i
know and like when was smallville
smallville was like 2001 to 2011 or
something
um i don't know what it is man
but
you stuck in my head for years i never
watched the show or maybe like came
across that episode once and you were in
it
and i don't know there's just actors in
this world that like stuck with me and
you were one of them and i don't know
exactly why
you know where you just like i mean
that's a good thing yeah you really i
think
they're
um
you have a quality
that i think some of my characters have
is this like
it's a
the bad guy but he's so charming at it
you know i appreciate it and that
there's something that's the key it's
the key is to i always say is
play it grounded and
you don't
no one's
shows off their evil yeah they cover it
yeah well no one's a the villain in
their own story
that's one of my famous lines in the in
this moment
i am the villain of the story it was one
of my favorite things to say when i get
kind of like thank you well you kind of
did that i saw it because i saw it made
for love oh yeah hbo series yeah no and
i want like he's and you're the
character like really framed as a he's a
bad guy but like
for some reason by the end of it you're
still kind of likable and it was kind of
frustrating to watch i was like that's
good that's the point right again no
one's the villain in their own story so
maybe that's why you're getting cast so
much in roles because you have this
likability and they're like oh we could
see him play that guy but like he'll
you'll like him you won't instantly hate
him i i guess i don't know do you ever
go into a project being like is this the
character they're going to love or hate
i you just kind of like play the scene
and play the story more than anything
i've seen you don't have an agenda like
when you go into it you just say hey
these are the lines i'm going to hit my
mark i'm going to play it a certain way
i mean
how does that work for you yeah i would
say more than anything like as in
i don't know if you feel this way as an
actor i've said this quote so many times
but you're a color in someone else's
palette you could be the best blue but
you can only be blue right but again you
could work with them as much as you can
but you're not the the painter yeah
you're just the color i mean you've i
mean you're doing all this great stuff
the many saints of newark that just came
out yeah no time to die working with
daniel craig i mean i read that i'm just
like you got so many things going but i
want to take it back i want to see like
did you always want to be
an actor from a from a young age no
no i just uh no i didn't know what i
wanted to do when i was young i was what
did you do when you were young like
everybody else you played out in the in
the woods you know
like rode bicycles i i don't know really
it wasn't um
yeah it wasn't i wish i had something
that was crazy i had definitely like add
or something that was just all over the
place
don't we all
um
but yeah it wasn't i was never afraid
to be on stage i guess like if like our
school was doing something they would
always ask me to m.c just because i'd be
the only kid that would be like okay
i'll do it how do you emcee a show like
i don't know it was like whenever you
were a kid like you're billy magnussen
and you're watching into the woods yes
ps97 hey yeah yeah exactly doing a bunch
of i don't know you just had charisma at
a young age i guess i don't know
were you now listen were your parents
very supportive like you know i had i
come from dysfunction so you know i
could talk all day about my family but
those that listen know that i i have
that did you have any kind of
dysfunction or were you just did you
have a normal upbringing uh i don't know
what's normal i had mine
what do you remember uh i come from a
big like uh catholic family in new york
you know there was my dad had like seven
sisters and two brothers and then the
amount of cousins i had growing up in
new york and they were all my grandma
ruth was like that was my grandma really
really i have ruth on tattooed on my arm
oh beautiful ruthie is she still with
you no she's she's sadly yeah mine too
years ago she was a blessing i got the
other one though the lithuanian one
what's her name otilia
my otilia
she's lithuanian she has that accent she
talks like this yeah so we call her
moltula mothula what is motula it means
loved one because buna is grandma in
lithuanian but we say mothula
because she was like i'm not going to be
called grandma don't you dare do that
right right
don't age me yeah yeah i never meet
someone with a grandma ruthie in fact i
do this thing on instagram where i i i
do this uh
snapchat like grandma looking woman and
i'm like hi everyone it's it's aunt
ruthie and i do this whole did she have
the new york accent and all that my
grandma oh yeah she did she always had a
big cigarette in her mouth oh big ash
that was about to fall and i go hey
you're going to burn the house down get
out of here
[Laughter]
but you so you had a big family yeah so
i grew up just and there was a lot to
sift or fight through i guess you could
say but i think it was very supportive
but once she passed away the family
like spread out a lot isn't that
something that's what happened with my
grandmother when she died everybody
there was no more meeting place yeah
yeah you know the matriarch was gone and
now everybody kind of like uh spread out
and
live their own lives it's kind of sad
though those days where you're all
together and you're eating and you're
bitching and people are arguing in the
kitchen oh it was crazy it was always
there was never a dull moment you know
there was always something going on and
i do miss it and like i think i crave
that as an older man like i would like
to have that do you think you want to
have kids and a family yeah you do yeah
yeah i want to do the whole thing but
you have to be in a relationship and i
have to do that yeah and right now
you're single yep that's that's what i
am hey perpetually single i mean la is a
tough city why is it so tough is it
you know people in the midwest always
say you know my friends where i grew up
in indiana i was born in new york but
they always are like you know
why why aren't you married and why
aren't you and it's just it's different
in the midwest it's the mentality of
like people wanting family in there it's
just i guess i don't know if there's
that much more to do maybe la there's
just so much scenery and there's like oh
there's this no i don't i think this
city just naturally gravitates people
who are on an individual journey more
than anything and that's the priority
over
uh a partner selfishness is what you're
saying there's a yeah
yeah i would say so well i guess like if
you want to have a career you have to do
everything you can to have that career
and there's
something
impedes that which is crazy because i i
think
all this [ __ ] is chaos and there's
opportunity and it's either you swing
when you got the opportunity or you
don't you know yeah and then i i'm not
afraid to like fail you know and i think
are you really not afraid to fail i
think like this tattoo i got it's you i
always know i always
reminds me it reminds me that my friends
are [ __ ] um but what is it what does
it say it's just a string
okay it's a string i thought it was
actually a string yeah no it's a string
and like you have other friends that
have that no because they were like we
would like graduate college and
you know they're like let's get tattoos
we were drinking off the wagon down
mcdougall street in new york and i was
like okay i'll go first and i got my
tattoo and [ __ ] buddies didn't do it
and i'm like are you [ __ ] kidding me
dudes were you drunk of course you're 22
in new york just going crazy yeah and
they didn't get it so it shows you how
much they care about you [ __ ] and i
still love them yeah you still love them
even though they didn't but it
represents facing a fear i for some
reason any time
i've been very like i don't know if a
big fear is in front of me i have to go
right into it that means i have to do it
really no matter how scared you are no
no even if it's like karaoke or
something
okay i hate it and because i'm so scared
of it i'm like god damn it i have to do
it right yeah but it's like that's kind
of been my driving force anything that
like puts me off weirdly i'm like that's
where i'm going have you failed yeah
plenty of time you have what have you
failed at failed at so many things um
specifically i think trusting yourself a
lot
that's where failure comes from when you
don't trust yourself isn't it yeah i
think so it's where you like avoid
something that's deep inside you and you
keep pushing it down or hiding from it
um
and that's a big i think that's the
biggest failure what is what is that
what is that the one thing that what's
the one thing that scares you the one
thing you're afraid of failing at
not trying
god
i mean you're such a that's such a good
attitude not trying i think i don't try
sometimes because i'm like i do not want
to set myself up for a failure there's
that quote like the the biggest regret
is not drawing or something like that
yeah i would rather regret
all right i would hate to regret not
trying
like to not see where it goes not go on
the adventure not go around the
riverbank right know i've got to go into
pocahontas but you
but you had to learn that like i mean
you had to have like
were your parents loving or like billy i
love you i'm proud of you they were like
that they were affectionate and like i
remember going to church like as a kid
and
you know we would hug my dad all the
time and my mom and people would come up
to him and be like wow your your sons
are so affectionate towards you and
right it just kind of was the household
we were in see not me dude i'm sorry
what was the trauma i never kissed we
don't all have traumas we definitely
don't know
but i never you know i never kissed my
father my father never looked at me and
said i love you i'm proud of you you're
doing great uh whatever you do i'll
support you i never heard any of those
things so
it's surprising that i'm even here
talking to you right now well that's
that shows the the strength that you
have within you already you don't need
it but sometimes you have to look at
that strength and go look what you
accomplished look what you that's what i
need to do more is kind of look at look
at that look at what you've done look
what brought you here look how you got
here
yeah yeah but did it do you take the
time to reflect do you ever celebrate
yourself i think you do with the with
what the the 50 the 50 top hashtag oh
god that's everyone ever you said don't
bring it up go ahead say it bill go
ahead and say it say tell them what you
see i i see a lot of cool things
actually there's only one thing of me up
there too there's a picture of me and
steve martin but there's a picture of me
with the 50th
most eligible bastard that's the only
picture of me i have in the house the
rest are just movie stuff and but it's
the podcast room and it's in a distance
and the one thing you see that makes
everybody listening think that i am ego
and i don't know
no i mean we all are we all can be we
all can be but you have to you only get
one point of view yeah i guess that's
true so what was it that got you really
into acting what was it besides you
started em seeing like in high school
for for things no it wasn't i was a big
jock i was actually i was
right i was a big wrestler i did
football i wrestle two really wait wait
class uh so i was such a low weight
class that i was 16 and one and 12 of
them were forfeits because no one
weighed that little
no one was that light
so i was like i'm 16 and one i was like
nobody could wrestle you you weigh eight
pounds yeah i mean i was a really small
kid i was the smallest kid in my high
school
i think you're taller than me man i'm
six foot now but i grew after high
school i grew like eight inches or nine
inches were you always in shape and
always tall and always no i i think i'm
built like a brick [ __ ] house like but
you're you're so solid yeah yeah so i
was like 160 like as a freshman are you
kidding me yeah so you played you
wrestled were you a good wrestler i was
pretty good my brother's the real one he
was a heavyweight state champion in
georgia but wow yeah dude now wait a
minute we forgot something what's up bro
your dad was a a kickboxer yeah
professional kickboxer yeah he did so
did he toughen you up
um he taught me a lot of martial arts i
think again like in the 80s and 90s
martial arts was like a huge huge thing
right after the karate kid yeah and then
so he kind of brought me into that fold
growing up i remember like having to
walk to get my like yellow belt
uh i think like six miles in the snow in
new york because he's like this is going
to make you a man are you serious frozen
i don't think he ever said those words
but i think it was like for him he was
like this is a journey my son must take
you know yeah me just kidding me like i
don't wanna
jesus did you get picked on at school at
all you were always a bigger kid so you
didn't get really bullied no i just i
i'm not looking to fight anyone i also
like
trap like we moved out of new york i
left new york at eight years old and
moved down to miami moved to miami went
to georgia after that so i was like i
was always the new kid in school weirdly
and you got to like redefine yourself a
little bit i think
i don't know do you have friends from
kindergarten still
no i have a friend from like
when you say friend do you mean someone
you still hang out with i guess i know a
lot of people my age that know people
that they've went through a whole grade
system with their whole life and they're
still friends and you're like i never
had that i never had a solidifying group
growing up it was always malleable and
changing and like right long-term
relationships are
uh tough for me maybe that affected you
maybe somehow
it's like you're always perpetual you're
just you're moving you're changing your
you know because as an actor you gotta
you gotta go different places you gotta
film you gotta yeah leave for three
months and that's hard to have a
relationship with someone who is not
really comfortable with themselves or
yeah trust is a big thing yeah you know
all they hear in tabloids is uh this
actor cheated or this actor did this or
this you know actress i'm not that's
i don't know
well i'm just saying malleable like you
know it's like you know
yeah i don't do that either yeah
i mean when i was younger i mean if i
went off and did the movie i usually
didn't have a relationship i never i i
never have relationships what am i
talking about
i mean i i do but they just never work
out i'll be i think you'll find it
someday you do i do i hope so yeah
because i mean i'd like to i think it's
about choice a lot of times
it's a choice you make every day
i think tell me more
oh
i'll tell you more well you seem to have
some knowledge of this i have no
knowledge because it doesn't seem to
work out for me
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at sonos i don't know how
many times i have to tell you this but
sonos makes the best product out there
that's my personal opinion i've had
sonos devices in my house for nearly 18
years
i wouldn't know what to do without it i
could play a different song in each room
of the house i could play the party mode
in the living room and friends are over
i could be in my uh my my bedroom
playing sexy music to myself there's all
sorts of things you could do it's
compact it's beautiful you don't need
speakers but you know unless you really
want them but and they have this new
product called rome sonos rome is the
ultra portable smart speaker that allows
you to bring the sonos experience
wherever you go it weighs less than a
pound and it's a premium durable design
makes it perfect for the home and for on
the go ryan tell us more when you are
home rome connects to your wi-fi network
and the rest of your sonos system and
then automatically pairs with your phone
on bluetooth when you're on the go for a
seamless experience using automatic true
play tuning roam smartly adapts to your
surroundings and whatever you're
listening to and creates sound that's
astonishingly detailed and perfectly
balanced control rome using the app
apple airplay 2 or your voice with
amazon alexa or google assistant with
sonos you can start with one speaker and
expand your system over time like i have
all sonos speakers connect over wi-fi so
you can group speakers in different
rooms and play music throughout your
home you can also listen to different
radio stations i listen to stern i
listen to
my own playlists i listen to an 80s
channel it's really amazing sonos and
rome is just a new bonus that they just
came up with the technology is just
amazing and i love my folks at sonos so
thank you sonos this
podcast is sponsored by the wonderful
people the wonderful product
at sonos inside of you is brought to you
by
geico your good friends at geico guys we
want life to be easier i told you this
when i go to a grocery store i don't go
to a grocery store i have someone get my
food
it's uh it's easier for someone to bring
you food because that's kind of who i am
i like to
minimize my uh energy
uh and i don't like to do too much and
geico makes life a lot easier they have
this bundling policy that's just amazing
you could pay your homeowners renters
insurance along with your auto policy
one fell swoop it's easy it's geico easy
whether you rent your home you own your
home geico makes it easy it's as simple
as that um everybody knows the name
geico so um we already have so much to
do around the house so much to do around
the life in general and um all you do is
this
you go to geico.com
g-e-i-c-o you've heard him you've heard
the name ryan haven't you oh i've heard
the name yes you just you freaking go to
geico.com you get a quote you see how
much you
can save it's guy co-easy visit
geico.com today that's
geico.com inside of you is brought to
you by monk pack healthy snacks have a
bad reputation folks and let's be honest
most don't taste very good
they don't fill you up and they
certainly don't satisfy your cravings
this episode is sponsored by monk pack
who makes snacks that taste like our
favorite sugary treats but with one gram
of sugar or less monk pack keto nut and
seed bars contain one gram of sugar or
less two to three grams of net carbs and
they're only 150 calories wow and
they're great for anyone following a
keto lifestyle and the perfect snack for
anyone who is trying to eat better or
cut back on sugar and carbs without
sacrificing taste you know it's it's
important because we're always on the go
we live a fast lifestyle uh you know and
it's easy to just stop by a fast food
restaurant and get a burger and greasy
fries and just you know eat and feel
like crap and then get depressed and go
what am i doing
but with new monk pack you could feel
good about yourself knowing that you're
putting something better in your body
than a lot of the stuff that's out there
so it's easy for me to just grab a snack
and i'm on the go they're perfect for a
quick snack to satisfy your sweet tooth
without guilt enjoy monk pack keto nut
and seed bars as a quick breakfast while
running errands or after a workout yeah
i'm obsessed with these bars just
obsessed and
probably eat more than i should
uh i got to be fully stocked with these
with these bars so i could be on the go
and i don't i try not to keep any junk
food around the house i just keep my
monk pack try it for yourself folks and
you'll see and we have a special deal
for our listeners get 20 off your first
purchase of any monk pack product by
visiting monk that's m-u-n-k
monkpack.com and entering our code iou
at checkout and monkpak is so confident
in their product it's backed with a 100
satisfaction guarantee so you know what
that means
it means if you don't like it for any
reason they'll exchange the product or
refund your money whichever you prefer
so to get started just go to
monkpack.com that's
m-u-n-k-p-a-c-k monkpack.com
select any product enter the code i owe
you a checkout and save 20 off your
purchase monk pack delicious nutritious
food you can count on we thank them for
sponsoring the podcast
what were you talking about i don't know
life
was talking about life
life i mean
so your dad was a kickboxer yeah and
what was your mom doing she was like an
aerobics instructor so you had this
athletic family doing
jazzercise in the house well your dad's
kickboxing so he's more of a carpenter
and like i remember i think he like won
a fight and he really like beat someone
up and there's actually here's a
um
a plaque that's
on my birthday five years before i was
born of him like standing over a guy and
that was his like fight because he just
he's like i can't do this it was
different from sparring sparring you're
not hurting someone right and like he
hurt someone and he was like i can't do
it anymore did he teach you that like
sort of about like you know you don't
want to hurt someone you don't want to
start fights you don't want to be a good
role model in that regard yeah yeah i
think you
definitely stand up for your beliefs and
stand up for who you are but there's no
need to escalate things into physical
right don't get me wrong i've been in
fights but you can take care of yourself
though
you have to but but you can you can stay
on your own yeah of course you have to
have you lost a fight yeah you have yeah
i've won too you won it feels good to
win it's you know i'd rather not be in a
fight the people choose fights with you
because you're you're a handsome guy
they're like hey pretty boy and they
want to like
dude
last night i went to a concert last
night what concert hall notes no it was
at the fonda the span tennis i don't
know it was a buddy's friend a friend of
a buddies band right um
and i remember just like being like [ __ ]
let's go dance let's go dance in the the
pit or whatever and starting to dance
and people in [ __ ] l.a were not
dancing and elbowing a girl
legitimately pushed her like dropped her
drink on me there i was like what the
[ __ ] is going on
like are we not at a concert can we not
dance like what's that about it's like a
mosh pit i don't know what it is about
i don't know so what'd you do
laugh
just laughed you didn't say hey what the
[ __ ] no i was like i've got to keep
dancing what you can't ruin my time yeah
if you're having such a shitty time you
can't bother me people try to ruin my
time all the time i'll be at a concert
and what do you do when you go to a
concert ryan you dance you listen to
music and you stand up you enjoy
yourself right so i'm at a concert
a lot of concerts and maybe because i
listen to like light 70s and 80s music
but i'm there to watch holland oats or
lionel richie and i'm going to dance in
the ceiling i'm up there and they're
like dude you got these [ __ ] in the
back going sit down
and finally i turn around and i get mad
i go i'm at a [ __ ] concert dude
enjoying myself why don't you go home
with your [ __ ] binoculars yeah what
are you doing here
watch a dvd or the people that bust out
the
camera phones and they start recording
the console you're like what why'd you
come why didn't why why wouldn't you
just watch the concert youtube yeah
right i think there that is a big thing
with society right now that we are so
separated from the moment and like where
we are it's all about being present it's
so hard too i try so hard i'm listening
to eckhart tolle
you know and i'm like the power of now
in the car and you know it's like i got
a good one for you please uh michael
michael a singer yes um
write that down something surrender
living from a place of surrender
and what did you learn from that book um
that everything's a gift
every moment's a gift because to to have
this moment [ __ ] supernovas
13 billion years of reality had to
happen for this moment to happen and you
have nothing you can't affect it at all
you can just observe it and experience
it so just living your life
every day and being grateful and
thankful yeah i'm not saying it's easy
because you're a constant battle with
this guy up here yeah but and your
feelings and and the outside do you say
gratitude's in the morning do you pray
do you anything learn from your catholic
days going to church no nothing like
that i think i i'm fortunate to just
kind of have that when i wake up in the
morning i love
i love it i love feeling that sun i love
making my cup of coffee and
it's like my favorite part of the day
what do you do to to to be present what
do you what things do you do
um
are you saying like
yeah like some people will go to the
beach some people will go take a pike
some people will do nothing like me i
identify things i say what are the color
of your eyes what's the color of your
shirt i just try to
really just be here and like i'm color
blind are you ready what color your eyes
blue they are blue yeah
but like even that just like name things
and just be like where am i here instead
of being stuck up in my head like what's
around you do that unconsciously
subconsciously no uh sometimes you have
to force yourself it's a battle all the
time don't you think yeah like i'm here
i like your hat yeah i like
your headphones look good on your head
thanks buddy this is a nice jacket you
have ryan you have good facial hair you
have a good uh good head of hair yeah
take your shirt off bud yeah take your
shirt off yeah let's let's really be
let's really be president if we're going
to be present
give us a present
um so all right talk to me about like
when you got into acting and how that's
doing let's keep going into the acting
see this is like because you could think
it drives me crazy about l.a it's like
it's the only thing but you know what
well let's talk about this though you
did soap operas i loved it as the world
but see that that frightens me that's
one of my biggest fears because of the
amount of dialogue you have to learn for
a soap opera oh yeah 40 pages overnight
do you have a photographic memory no it
was a muscle but the guy that played my
dad in that show it would he would
literally have three pages of dialogue
and they would i don't know if you ever
did it so pop no look at me do i look
like i could be in a soap opera yeah why
not because i wasn't beautiful looking
you dude you're so talented again you
stuck with me you or at least from my
opinion i think you're talented thank
you thank you i appreciate it just well
i just never i mean i remember
auditioning for soap operas when i was
in new york for like days days oh you're
a new york guy yeah i was born in york
and then i moved to uh indiana and then
i went to college in kentucky and then i
moved back to new york but i remember
auditioning for like days of our lives
and yeah um because i like days of our
lives stefano and yeah those characters
but uh i never got a call back never
nothing for so far which is probably you
know i'm glad because all that dialogue
but but but talk to me about that um i
was the guy who played my dad he was so
good they would go 3-2-1 in action and
he would literally have the pages
and they go three two one he would put
it in his shirt and he would have the
whole thing memorable how is that
possible if i had that gift i'd be
fearless but it's a muscle i have to
admit like when i was doing it at that
time like the first few months was like
it was it was tough were you stressed uh
at first and then once you go [ __ ] it
yeah you let it go all of a sudden it
was just like a muscle memory you knew
what was going on you're there not
saying i hit the line every time but you
got finally an understanding especially
like being in the tv show at the the
length you were didn't become like just
kind of second nature it did become more
of a muscle but i always worried about
it i always wanted to know my lines i
the biggest fear i'm doing i'm doing a
movie coming up and like you know uh you
know
if i don't have the lines on me if i
don't have the script if i don't have
they wait if they're changing things
that's a big fear of mine i'm like i
want to know it so well that i can move
around i can pick up this this glass
right here and i can just talk to you
while i'm doing my lines because i know
them so well and i always read a lot
when i was younger about you know i
wouldn't say i read a lot but like you
know watching
you know
anthony hopkins talk about acting or
michael kane and saying learn your lines
that was a terrible cane but you know um
the more you know your [ __ ] and not just
going oh i got them because there's
sometimes i see people in the makeup
trailer and they're learning their lines
and i'm like how can you be great if
you're just learning your lines now how
can you be great i don't want to be i
think you're exactly right how can you
be great
when you do it that way right i dude i
think that's the trick i remember doing
a play it was a two-hander in new york
and i spent before the first table read
i had a
i hired someone to just come and read
half the play with me every day
and i just read it i never i never
memorized the line i just read the half
the play every day and by that first
table read i didn't even have to look at
the script are you serious yeah how
smart is that uh that was probably the
best thing i ever figured out to do like
right i didn't think it like i was just
like i don't want to be unprepared and
then once you get to that point you do
get to throw it all away it's just it's
there that's true i always remember that
the more you do a play the more you
rehearse the more you read it
you kind of get the lines yeah once you
know the story and you're like you know
but you never have to think about it
right yeah that's a that's like getting
into any character i think
it's it is that three months or two
months before
that you're just doing everything for
muscle memory you're just letting like
when i did paulie like just sitting in
that [ __ ] i would take a shower
paulie on uh the many saints of newark
which is now on hbo hbo max which you
can watch which you guys got to check
out but learning those mannerisms it was
just i had to live with them over and
over again so once i got to set with all
the [ __ ] and all the blah blah i didn't
have to think about those body or my
mannerisms or the lines or the the way
he spoke his cadence and all that stuff
but you but you did like
you knew this guy you met this guy who
played i only met him finally uh or tony
uh he was just on set one day and stuff
like that but it was all before i was
just like so had a youtube video oh you
watch youtube videos and i like i was
like i gotta figure out who tony is not
not paulie walnuts you know right
because obviously i think
the line between tony and paulie are is
very thin what's he like uh you're doing
it all wrong what the [ __ ] i do that
what are you doing no not at all how you
doing hey thanks for doing this you're
playing with me how cool is it just like
kind of like think to the side you
always talk the other side of his mouth
with this lisp so that's what you did
yeah
do that again that was cool how you did
that
you just i i know i'm doing like a bill
murray from caddysha
it was two years ago i did this thing so
it's like really it just came out now
muscle memory man
right wow i think i don't know so what
do you use kind of i don't know he had
this thing and i just thought i would
wear his mouth sat
yeah that's fine the best line i ever
heard was like i love that [ __ ]
like a brother and then he [ __ ] me in
the ass
is that paul one of the lines no that's
just him from the show and i was just
like
david chase writing that line is
brilliant because like it's just the
most absurd absurd line when you
auditioned for this i read somewhere
that you didn't even like you never had
seen sopranos no i never
no i had never seen it and i auditioned
for a different character in the film
and i didn't get it i failed i didn't
get it did they just offer you the other
role and they were like hey would you be
interested in
trying this route and i was like okay
and then i did you audition for that no
i didn't you didn't not that time no but
because i auditioned for another
character so you can't accept like
knowing what you're going to do and
sometimes that's hard when you get an
offer and you get on set and you're
starting to do this mouth thing like you
know i'm doing this well it's okay
there's like a road map when you have to
the character kind of already existed so
you're just
kind of following but they were excited
to see what you were bringing to no they
were not they hated me
[Laughter]
get out get out oh it was challenging it
was what do you mean
uh it was a challenging one that's all i
can say you could just say it was a
challenging role
no
it was the other stuff was challenging
it was just challenging being on set
yeah it was just like there was a lot of
cooks
uh i i'm gonna leave this you could
leave that alone i could leave it alone
but overall did you love the other
actors you were oh that's the thing like
the crew the guy the crew and the the
other actors were fantastic world
theater guys so we had like this we we
had uh what not nomenclatures
where you could speak the same language
and we could talk about and the trust in
the space was wonderful because everyone
is doing some weird [ __ ] right you know
and
yeah but how do you trust yourself when
you're the people around you are not
kind of like you're like
you're just doing your lines you're
reading them you're acting them out
you're trusting yourself is it hard to
trust yourself when there's some chaos
going on whatever that was of course of
course so you just stick with it no no
you just let go man what are you gonna
do you're you're there you're gonna do
what you're gonna such a good attitude
yeah billy magnussen
he's got such a good attitude here
thanks man um what was the hardest part
about that about doing that part about
being in being in the uh many uh saints
of new york i think it was letting go it
was like just keep going down this
avenue just keep going like this is what
you rehearse this is what you practice
this is what you prepared so trust it
you've done this process and so many
other projects why don't you just
continue down it it's challenging
inside of you is brought to you by chili
sleep you know science tells us ryan
that the best way to achieve and
maintain consistent deep sleep is by
lowering core body temperature
temperature controlled sleep restores
testosterone levels fellas
repairs muscle after a hard day's work
and improves cognitive function so you
always start your day feeling sharp and
alert chilly sleep makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions that
help you improve your entire well-being
chilly sleep makes the uhuler that's
o-o-l-e-r and cube sleep systems hydro
powered temperature controlled mattress
toppers that fit over your existing
mattress to provide your ideal sleep
temperature
these luxury mattress pads keep your bed
at the perfect temperature for deep
sleep whether you sleep hot or cold
these sleep systems are designed to help
you fall asleep stay asleep and give you
the confidence and energy to power
through your day imagine waking up and
not feeling tired it's just a glorious
feeling chilly sleep can help make that
happen for an extra layer of comfort
they also make the chili blanket the
only weighted blanket that can also be
paired with a control unit for the
ultimate sweat-free
sleep and you know
with all my back problems and neck
problems and you know it's hard to fall
asleep and i there's nothing i like
better than having a nice cool bed and
getting under my covers it just is so
refreshing and relaxing and uh
head over to
chilisleep.com i o u that's c h i l i s
l e e p
chili sleep dot com slash iou
to learn more and check out a special
offer available exclusively for inside
of you listeners and for only a limited
time
that's chile c-h-i-l-i sleep dot com
slash iou to take advantage of our
exclusive discount and wake up refreshed
every day inside of you is brought to
you by better help what would we do
without better help ryan are you still
doing the better help still doing the
better help and is it helping it is
helping i love it i love it i think you
know we're in such a climate
and i think the climate's always been
there there's always been stressful
times for people there's always it's not
like life gets any easier it's just like
how do we make life easier
and that's better help better help the
folks at better health can really help
you whether you're struggling with grief
relationships or stress or you're having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you it's for me
it's for ryan it's for millions and
millions of people around the world it
helps you live a better life better help
is secure online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with licensed professional
therapists betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
accredited therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist how easy is that you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available i'll tell you
you know therapists in los angeles can
cost
hundreds and hundreds of dollars and
better help is just a great option
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help that
they're recruiting additional therapists
in all 50 states
um
i just love better help i they've been a
sponsor for a long time and they're
helping a lot of people and i want to
thank betterhelp
inside of you is sponsored by betterhelp
and our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash inside try better help
many of my friends have texted me and
said does this really work and they seem
to have figured out that it does
so check out betterhelp and get that
discount
betterhelp.com
inside
do you watch yourself yeah how does a
carpenter look at a table after he built
it yeah but there's some some actors who
don't like to watch i think that's weird
man it i think it's weird too and i
think it's [ __ ] i think every actor
says no i don't watch myself they watch
themselves
guaranteed yeah of course they do
because again you can't see what you're
doing you can't learn or you can't grow
unless they really don't and you're like
that's why they do the same thing over
and over again yeah yeah you have to you
have to be
invested in yourself not in like a
selfish way but like this is your the
in the acting career like we are the
product that's what sucks like you are
the product so you have to constantly
mold it and shape it and work on it and
right which is exhausting i the problem
i had actually one of my biggest
failures was um connecting my self-worth
to my career and i hate that feeling
explain that explain that um your
self-worth to your career like are you
are you worthy yeah are you good enough
to be this part to be a successful actor
to be someone that people want to hire
no you i you know this this game is a uh
it's a game of knows how many notes have
you gotten and a million it takes an
entity i'm waiting on a note today
you know the president was in the
meeting and he felt i felt like he loved
it but like you know i'm so used to
rejection now that it's just like
how am i gonna prepare and usually i'm
like okay let's go to the next one let's
go the next one but sometimes you go
this
this is it me or no
well maybe but no it's like this is too
good what's the problem yeah what is
this sometimes it probably sometimes has
nothing to do with actually the project
that's what's crazy and that's what i'm
saying like talk like disassociate
yourself from
the the product like the the career how
do you do that i have no clue man you're
still you're still wondering about that
you still have self-doubt you still like
you of course
you do of course
again but all you can do is let it go
you say that so freely like i just let
it go do you really just let it go no
there's nights i've stayed up there's
weeks i've gone through this i have been
benders i've been on vendors i've been
self-sabotaging myself over and over
again but like
yeah
but what what value does that actually
bring to my life what's not fine brings
nothing
yeah so it's just kind of constantly
going back it's a practice you know it's
not something like you'll uh run lines
and you're nervous and you're like want
to be great you get on there and you
know the first take's not great you're
like in your head a little bit you know
you have to and sometimes you say to
yourself
[ __ ] everybody here
because at the end of the day when they
say they say cut
i'm on screen yeah so what do i give a
[ __ ] about anybody just have and those
are the days where i was the best or i
just said this is for me i'm [ __ ]
full of confidence and it wasn't all the
time yeah but when i felt that i go why
can't you feel like that all the time
what is it about that why can't we just
once we it's almost like my mind is like
you're great so the next time you should
be great yeah why don't you why do you
feel like [ __ ] right now why don't you
feel confident so i wanted to rephrase
what you kind of said you said [ __ ]
everyone here i think that that everyone
here is actually yourself and you go
[ __ ] myself [ __ ] myself [ __ ] myself
that's not everyone has nothing to do
with anyone else it's actually the fight
you're having in your your own head yes
so how do you shut that guy up and go
what do you do what do you do to shut
him up i it's hard i don't know that
look at someone's eyes and say your eyes
are brown
the the sky's blue i don't i again it's
uh i actually
doing the solo pop is one of the
one of the best gifts i've ever gotten
in my career because it was like right
off the bat and ellen uh she played my
mother on the show ellen degeneres no
ellen dolan i think
and um lovely woman
and i remember one of the days like i
was probably like
maybe three months into it like uh doing
soaps and it was one of those days where
i was like not hitting my marks and i
was like god damn it it's just like
really struggling and i was like oh my
attitude was shitty and she came up to
me she was like say your [ __ ] lines
no one gives a [ __ ] about you worrying
or being bad okay say your lines we all
want to go home no one gives a [ __ ]
and like to realize that like i was
putting all this pressure on me and like
doing all this other [ __ ] it was like
that's not the point of it you know you
are a part in this wheel and wow
yeah it was just that kind of that could
have crushed an actor no it actually
helped it was it helped so much because
it was just so honest and i think
um
that
that [ __ ] always resonates with me i
think that's kind of what i hate about
hollywood a little bit is the deception
of it all
like you could just tell me no or don't
do that or anything don't like pussyfoot
around it just like
put it on the table like it doesn't help
anyone to
you know
not hurt their feelings right you know
because it's not about you're actually
doing someone a service by being
authentic and honest right at least i
feel when you watch yourself i mean did
you watch your performance in the many
saints and go
huh that's pretty good yeah like they
did and i was like
you know they're like all right this
works it worked it worked because i had
no i had no clue at least actually when
i did the adr
uh i just remember like
oh okay okay i'm not i can like go to
bed and like feel what were you worried
about that you were coming across as
over the top or
everything everything you just worry
about that [ __ ] yeah of course i know
one college and said hey we saw the
dailies you're great
um no no one said no one said that you
just hope that this is a big deal this
is the prequel for sopranos this is but
you never get back to that you never
watched the show at the time because
someone said or maybe you said you
couldn't afford hbo at the time college
no of course i kind of worked hbo no
no um yeah no never never watch it until
the finally i got the job so i just like
binged it it's a great series like the
present i still haven't seen it oh
the whole
premise
a mobster going to therapy
and like it's fantastic a great setup
for that like right i think it's
brilliant who's your favorite character
in the show
i mean tony sorano who's your favorite
yeah i mean james ganafini was is an
unbelievable actor i remember seeing him
in god of carnage on broadway and he was
fantastic he just had a presence and a a
light around him that was just left was
it called levity is that what it is
weight
weight levity i don't know is that like
a magnetism just like magnetism is
magnetism yeah right yeah um do you ever
get star struck because like when you're
working with daniel craig on uh no time
to die
i mean and you've got this you know
you've got fight scenes and stuff like
are you are you like oh [ __ ] daniel
craig
yeah yeah sure but again it's not about
the individual it's more like my
expectations of it um so you don't get
like you get a little starstruck at
first i got like weird star shark i
remember meeting bill irwin the first
time right and like i was i just love
clowns and he was like the famous most
famous clown in the world right and i
remember meeting him on broadway i was
just like [ __ ] bill irwin no one knew
who what clown was he no he just had
this clowning bit he you just do these
bits and they're like all on youtube and
you met him and you were starstruck yeah
and he's a nice guy and yeah wonderful
guy but you think you would have said no
i got starstruck when i met demi moore i
got starstruck when i met uh
yeah no demi was great like you again i
one
[ __ ] the first time i met
a meryl streep
i was doing meryl streep you did you
worked with meryl streep and into the
woods yeah she was into the
holy [ __ ] i got to watch this she's the
one who got
tell me tell me please i was doing a
play so i was doing a play vanya and
sonia martian spike the one you got
nominated yeah sigourney weaver was like
my girlfriend
david hyde pierce we're doing the show
at lincoln center and after the show
david and i shared a dressing room knock
on the you know knock on the door uh i
open it and all i can think is like
you're her you're the you're the chick
you're you're i couldn't think of her
name couldn't think of meryl streep's
name
well when she when you open the door and
it's meryl streep you're like what the
[ __ ] yeah
yeah and then uh
uh what'd you say
hey is david there you're like oh it
wasn't you're great
oh yeah well
the story cuts to like i get into the
woods i auditioned for it whatever
um and she basically during like a table
read leans over and goes i got you this
job
you know because of the play
are you serious yeah meryl streep fought
for you i don't know if she fought for
me but i think she gave me the
opportunity to audition she was like
get this guy in here
so wow yeah
did you get a picture well you worked
with her so you have photos of you and
meryl are you cool now could you text
merrell and say what's up no no nothing
like that anybody you became friends
with the sigourney the thriller yes
great you could text her yeah you could
say sigourney what's up yeah all the
time what do you call her sigourney oh
okay yeah you have a nickname like gorny
if you're sick no no
sig or
she goes by sir i think so hey ripley
what's going on
that's amazing what was this uh you had
this unbelievable fight scene i haven't
i haven't seen this with daniel craig
yeah yeah yeah crazy no time to die so
crazy talk to me about that and how do
you prepare for that how do you
months of uh like there was this french
uh um
what do you call it core uh fight
choreographer yeah like the the combat
what do you call what stunt crew stunt
crew yeah and they brought me in you
know a few months before i started and i
would go to london and train and we just
worked on the dance of the fight how
long was the was the fight
the fight itself like on screen
i couldn't 45 seconds and it probably
took you how many months to really get
it down not but i i have dance training
and i think it's all dancing weirdly you
know that choreography right um i had it
fast but you know you're just
you're waiting to shoot the thing so you
just go and practice and all your kick
your your fighting and your karate that
you took to it all helped out in this
yeah of course and like how to throw a
punch properly how was daniel craig was
he
tell me about how gentlemen he's a
gentleman he's a great guy he's funny
um i i feel so fortunate to sit across
the table with from him and like just
get to know him and like toss jokes
around in between takes and he's a real
gentleman and he he is a great number
one you know have you worked with any
bad number ones
yeah you have you won't talk about that
though no it's not worth it it's not
worth it all i can say is all i can say
is like
when someone makes a project about
themselves rather than the project
that's when i know it's bad
it's the the biggest issue because we
all everyone that's standing in the room
agreed to do this project not [ __ ] with
someone's ego
so what do you do what do you do when
someone's got an ego someone's like you
know you're like ah this is about them
how do we do you just what do you do
what's your approach
let them do what they got to do
and just worry about yourself worry
about everybody else you want me to call
you like sir
underbatch i don't i don't care yeah
sure whatever so benedict cumberbatch
was an [ __ ] no no no no no no no no
no you didn't work with him did you no
never no no i'm a big fan though yeah
who isn't he's like fantastic see when i
i get a little star struck like you know
did you ever see his like thing when he
was the dragon and like the cgi [ __ ] no
him crawling around on the floor like oh
it's great yeah always what is it
[ __ ] unbelievable he was uh the
dragon in the hobbit the new hobbit
smoke yeah so we had to put on the suit
with the dots on it and he crawling
around the corner
dude homeboy so hard i'm like i see the
dragon uh
really he was a dragon yes he looked
like a dragon and even his cadence was
just like so oh he didn't look anything
like a dragon that's the thing
he's wearing the suit yeah but he could
buy it by his mannerisms in his physical
oh yeah i see a tail basically he's like
using the tail and you're like that's
insane
his imagination is so great and like him
[ __ ] um
circus andy circus like circus i dream
of doing roles like that those guys are
unbelievable put a mask on me put me in
that i would love have you done anything
like that yet
no the most is the prosthetics or like
big characters like in aladdin i had a
big aladdin i hear you were great in
that 30 seconds of screen time but i
hear you were i was a fun character it
was i my friend troy said you know
anything about this billy magnuson guy
he's like yeah aladdin oh yeah 30
seconds
30 seconds and what'd you do if i got
that much
and it was screen capture no no it was
it was just
like a character no it was a real
character i just put a character i'm
just saying
more just like big characters i love
that like the bigger you can make a
character and like the world you can
play in that's what i want i want to
like
transform and just do andy circus [ __ ]
who do you want to work with besides
andy circus who's who are some of the
actors that you
yeah i'd work with you there we go bud i
got some projects man let's go i'm not
kidding you better answer your phone
though or maggie over there you publish
this better answer phone sounds good man
no i got some good stuff man yeah you're
great i mean you've done so much stuff
and you're now older you're 36 36 do you
feel 36 yeah
i feel 49.
i'm 49 and i feel every bit of it ryan
how old are you 33
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you it's just unbelievable
how much better you feel at 33 than 49
yeah and even 36. yeah i feel i you know
it's crazy you just your mentality
changes that's for sure i think there's
still so much to learn and stuff i
imagine where were you at 36 where was
your headspace um let me see i was
you know i think i was
i was just caught up in all of it and i
was just doing it and you don't stop and
just non-stop and then all of a sudden
you know
it wasn't until i was like 44 45 i
started going what's it all about man
why did i have to [ __ ] care about
what's it all about why couldn't i
continue to just not give a [ __ ]
yeah because i think
in my mind there's got to be something
more there's got to be
something more than just doing something
getting attention getting credit for it
being
you know people like you there's got to
be more there's going to be purpose
and so tell me keep going down this
rabbit hole
well you know just like you know uh
going to
working at the ronald mcdonald house and
helping kids and like doing movie nights
with them and then becoming friends with
one of the kids who has cancer and
becoming close friends with his family
and just driving up there to hem at two
hours and spending the day with him and
worth more than it was worth more than
anything worth more than anything and
like i love this kid he's like my
brother so much the point where he has
terminal cancer that
i find myself praying saying remember
the exorcist you ever see the exorcist
remember at the end when he says come
into me take me
the priest says yeah i say that i'm like
let this kid live man let this kid have
a wonderful life just take me i've had a
good life man i'm good and it's not like
i'm
talking in a macabre sort of way it's
just like it just it is unfair and uh by
by hanging out with him
and seeing what a great
just a great human being he is and how
he looks at life and how things get him
excited
that
for instance
he uh
he likes to sing but he's never really
done anything professional and you know
he's not like a singer but he's
somebody said hey you like this blake
shelton song lonely tonight
and so they brought him into the studio
and he just sang it
and you know it was already recorded the
song was recorded
and uh
so he did it and he just loved it i
listened to it like oh my god this is so
good it sounds so great
and his dad texts me and says hey i
don't know if you know blake shelton i
go i don't
he goes but you know if you can get if
there's any way we can get this video
this song to blake shelton and i wrote a
letter to blake shelton really and my
publicist got it to blake shelton and
within two days blake shelton sent a
video oh and i showed it at his house
for him and seeing his eyes light up and
blake's like that's the hardest song
i've ever sang
and you crushed it if you were in the
voice i would have hit you right in and
you know just talking to him and and his
eyes were just like
and just that i could even do anything
to make that happen
meant the world to me i believe that
makes me feel so much better than all
the other stuff it seems like it's
superficial but
there's another good book you should
check out yeah it's called the second
mountain and uh i think this is what
it's about it's like there's this um
you you have that journey that you
climbed in your 30s 20s and 30s and
everything and you're like it's my
career my career and then all of a
sudden you find like this kid is an
example of this other fulfilling thing
in your life that's actually worth value
than this
other thing that you were climbing to
the top and you you made it man you you
have a successful career you did it and
then you probably were like why am i
empty
hundred percent i kind of fought that my
whole life i think there's that
feeling of like why do i feel empty
there's just and people will sit there
and go you have a house you have friends
you have you know you're not broke
you're you have a career you have all
these things
and i acknowledge it and i'm like going
yeah yeah yeah
but why don't i feel it i hear you and
so what do you do what do you what is it
that you do do you do i'm in the valley
right now between the two i feel i feel
i'm in the valley like i am so
i have so many great opportunities in my
life and great things that come and then
i find myself sitting there being like
i'm empty i feel empty a little bit
um
because i i think personally i think
it's family and like it's like community
and all this stuff and like our career
is very isolating and
you're put to the side and again i'm
grateful for all of it yeah but there is
that hunger for like purpose
actual purpose
i mean so everybody
i think everybody just wants that it's
like you hear about those people who
just constantly work and i always think
what are they covering up yeah they
always have to work they always have to
be on they always have to get the next
run
right well what happens if they stop
running because eventually we all stop
running yeah and you face it you face
you face it no matter how old you are
and so i'm kind of grateful that i'm
facing it now
in a lot of ways and so it's just like
what do you do about it yeah and how
many times would you honestly say you've
redefined yourself to yourself
i i don't know or have you always been
the same person i think i'm redefining
myself now i think now is in the last
five years you know going to get help
you know just like mentally i wasn't
ever not gonna would addicted to drugs
or alcohol but like getting my set and
clear and finding out who i really am
because i you know for me i grew up
uh
like i wasn't i didn't have the
relationship you had with your family i
mean i love my family and and god bless
them but uh i just feel like i was doing
everything
for attention like just to get attention
just some some people liked me
acknowledged me accepted me and that
kind of carried on where all of a sudden
i'm like wait a minute you've been doing
this since you're like 17 since you did
that first play in high school and so
it's not enough and they have this thing
i've talked about it but it's like love
and attention have the same feeling like
if you're get people admire you and you
they love what you're doing that's the
same feeling as love but the only thing
is is one isn't sustainable yeah one
sort of is like you know well it's
always the tank's always going to empty
out and like if you actually love
yourself right it's always going to be
filled yeah
it's a hard thing to do that's a hard
thing to do but i think if you do more
things for other people if you help
people if you i think that's the true
that then you can identify yourself
hopefully as someone who
isn't loving love and be loved love is a
giving act it's a giving away don't take
it right take love right you can only
give it
yeah i feel you know i feel like my my
grandmother
really [ __ ] loves me yeah she
probably does that's a good feeling
she's with us man she well she's my
grandma who's still alive blanche
she just said you know since the
beginning you know her my grandfather
used to just write me these letters that
were so proud of you and like and i
think they knew that i struggled you
know and yeah but they always write me
these letters and even my grandparents
like you know we're so proud of you and
all the work you've done but just know
that regardless of all this how much you
know we you know how much we've always
loved you yeah and i and i believe that
sometimes it's hard for me to believe
really believe that i can be i the doubt
because it's that self-doubt and yeah
because again probably a drama from
growing up being like i'm not getting
the attention or the right support i
need or my feelings being recognized
yeah and like my awareness dude we've
all been through it you don't believe it
you don't believe someone says i love
you and you're like oh thank you
thank you very much here yeah thank you
i love you too yeah but you're like no
dude i [ __ ] really love you yeah and
that's what i mean and then but it could
end there that's what's crazy and we
can't accept it yeah yeah i don't know
why we push it away and i think i think
you know i i'm i'm
i don't want to say wise enough but i'm
i think you're good you've got years
experiences i know that i am i know that
i am loved i know that there are people
in my life that love me and that that
feels good and i know that i i i love
you thank you i could turn to that i
could turn i love you too
that's right and i believe billy i
believe i believe that you're a lovable
person that you really love you too
well you know this has been this has
been a really great conversation the
funny thing is i don't know you and i
talked effort effortlessly to you i just
feel like it's just very easy you're
someone that
there's no intention
well there's no expectation it's just
more about
finding something from you or finding
something from me that you get that you
go
hey uh
we're all struggling through
we all end up at the same place it
doesn't matter who you are it's like how
do you get there you learn from people
yeah that's what this podcast is about i
think it's just learning you know maybe
someone takes something you said and
goes you know
what he what he said really made sense
to me and that's it most everything i
say that doesn't make sense no it makes
beautiful sense i think it does it
really does what are you what do you got
going on now because you've got some so
much going on many saints of newark is
on hbo max now when does no time to die
come out it's already out it's out it
came in out last friday last friday yeah
or yeah last friday
yeah so you got two blockbuster things
going on right now crazy crazy
opportunity
what's next what are you working on now
uh i have this film coming out called
the survivor uh with ben foster and
barry levinson directed it's going to be
on hbo
how tough was that that was again two
months preparation german so i had to
learn
a german accent through well
it's an english-speaking german accent
what's the one i remember where i lived
in munich with the nine-man frau
but i remember learning for this
audition and i never forgot it
i didn't get the part but i remember
learning german for the audition but it
was like but i remember saying things
like i lived in on prince getting
strauss into
next to the frieden's angle in munchin
you know
um i also know how to say well you blow
me that's my testimony
baby baby
baby baby baby baby and then say that
line baby baby
that doesn't sound sexy at all no it
doesn't sound sexy i'll be quiet now but
you have to learn a german accent
through an english like a british accent
so wait wait wait wait wait wait so
you're speaking british but like
it's british accent like a german who
learned english through a british accent
so let me hear something no
give me a give me an idea the german
people always wonder where it is yeah i
i don't know
that's great yeah
it was tough but then if i was speaking
to a german in the film i had to speak
german so
i would
i don't remember the lines
dude
awesome baby baby
yeah it was crazy so yeah german english
if i'm speaking to the the jewish people
and uh if i'm singing to german it would
have to be all in german have you seen
the movie yeah do you like it i did it
was a real passion project and ben
foster is he's incredible incredible do
you ever see lone survivor yeah god that
movie's so good dude homeboy's so good
he is so good he's so talented that's
great yeah i'm excited for you you got a
lot great stuff going on and you deserve
it you're a great guy and he's super
talented and thanks uh this is uh lastly
this is called [ __ ] talking with billy
magnussen [ __ ] talking these are my
patrons if you want to join patreon to
get back to the podcast or give a little
extra the podcast i love my patrons they
support the podcast so much but these
are just kind of rapid fire oh [ __ ] uh
by the way emily asks the game nightcast
seems like a great group of people to
hang out with who was the funniest to
film with the funniest
that's
bateman i could watch bateman do
anything he could he the way he delivers
a line it's just so dry and so
beautifully like the cadence of it he
has he has it down he he was just so
funny watch to hang out with lamar and
morris lamarr and morris i love that guy
and sharon horgan
i would die for her she's absolutely a
tragedy by the way how
beautiful is rachel mcadams she's
gorgeous and she's so sweet i met her
once at a party and she was so nice
she's so nice man how many guys just
crush how many women men everyone just
crush on rachel mcadams i mean she is
she's a she is who she is and a great
person i love her man
oh sharon horgan fantastic human being
really so funny i think i just saw an
interview with two of you they paired
you up yeah right we could not she's in
through the day yeah yeah no she's irish
irish irish yeah can you do an irish
accent uh no i could do it
made for love quickly became a must-been
show are you excited about the second
season do you have any idea on when it
will come out yeah we actually start
shooting on monday uh
season two so i'm really excited about
that and like where they're going to
take what's going on dude not really i
feel like i have no i'm like nothing to
do well maybe you have time to read one
of these books or you know work at the
wrong house
have you ever been to the magic castle
i'm a member shut up do you do magic
tricks i i don't do magic tricks but i
like magic tricks i love magic i'm like
a four year old watching magic i'm like
oh my god me too did you see that i'm a
big dork how do you put my name in an
orange
i put my name in an orange i'm gonna get
this tattoo how did he do it i flipped
the hell out same um
let's see i want to go to magic castle
if you want to hang out take the magic
i'll take you whenever you want i'm
ready just email me whenever you want to
go let's go um
the chief if you had to live on a
breakfast cereal the rest of your life
which one would it be uh lucky charms i
think i was going to say lucky charms
maybe some fruit loops
no or it's weird i would go honey nut
cheerios too i like honey nut but yeah
like but lucky charms all those she
turns give it all give me can you name
all the charms and lucky charms rainbow
heart
uh diamond diamond there's a dinosaur
diamond
how does the song
hearts and stars and rainbows and the
red balloon it ends with and the red
balloon doesn't it i think he got it my
dude there we go omar loved your
performance in the oath oh
simultaneously hilarious and terrifying
how did you approach playing such a
complicated character uh i had fun with
like baron holtz and was like can i just
i
all i could think of was like this guy
that used to work with my dad growing up
and i was like this is the guy the most
conservative uh like right-wing person
the stash all the haircut and everything
and it's the guy's dead serious
like
i think that's where humor lies it's
being dead
dead serious not deadpan dead serious
anything you're doing anything you're
saying commit to it it's real it's what
your character believes yes it's 100
and do you know like
no you're a wonderful man would he be a
good guest yeah ike's great he's he's
funny you know i wish i had bits or like
people that do bits like i just don't
what do you do impressions no not one no
come on you gotta do one do one
impression i mean everybody does walking
that's an easy one
your son
[ __ ] that he is and that [ __ ] or
girlfriend they took my narcotics
i always do that but like yeah you see
seven psychopaths no you haven't seen
sec seven psychopaths no fantastic films
right on ryan i'm gonna oh my god yeah
all right i'll watch it fantastic i
worked with walk and i loved i loved
watching
it's uh rockwell it's uh colin farrell
colin farrell
it is fantastic all right i'm in i'll
watch that i need something to watch
it's a wack ass but it's a
uh the guy did you see in bruges yeah
director yeah he's a playwright as well
would you ever do a horror movie
um here's my jam i have done when i was
like one of my first ones was called
blood knight the legend of mary
nice yeah i heard about that one
i remember i remember that title yeah i
don't think i saw it but i remember um
the only problem with doing horror films
is you shoot at night and i hate
shooting at night where you have to
shoot you're like
yeah i like my morning what is
lastly i know it's a stupid question no
what's your best take usually
the best take one take two or usually
take three is when i [ __ ] find oh
honestly it's when i'm driving home
being like i should have [ __ ] done
this
why wasn't i thinking that what the [ __ ]
i misinterpreted the whole [ __ ]
taking a shower at home you think it's
three months later god why didn't i do
that oh my god yeah do you hold on to
things do you let things go
it's both like when someone breaks up
with you
i hold i'll hold i'll hold it's certain
things it's certain things like i'll
hold on to
specific things that i where if i made
the choice
and i'm like oh man i need to work on
that on myself if it's someone else's
choice you can't really right do
anything about it can you let things go
are you someone that could just kind of
let things go and let bygones be by god
my friend recently told me he's like
dude sometimes you got to let things go
like i'll push on people be like but
what do you mean by that let's go let's
go down this conversation let's go down
the road he's like sometimes you just
gotta let it go bro
and i gotta work on you hold on to
things well again i think if
be specific in life
be make a choice
not making a choice drives me crazy like
living in a state of limbo you're like
what
do you make a choice who cares make a
choice
there's no there's no wrong answer it's
just left to right and your left might
fail so be it then go then go back right
who gives a [ __ ] right just don't do
nothing
favorite role you've ever done that you
go [ __ ] i killed it i loved it i'm in
this this was my favorite role i've done
so far
wow
i loved prince anders from aladdin it
was just i loved the character but then
there's like other experiences like i've
had that were just
man
i don't know like with the career i
doing a play doing tv film
all these years after they they mean
nothing to me now it's weird it's just
it doesn't exist anymore right and so
you know like the hunt we're always on
the hunt for the next
opportunity and like we fall in love
with the the work of it so like the film
coming out which i shot bond two years
ago
the the connection i have to it is
different right you know because in the
while doing it you're like oh what the
[ __ ] and then you slowly let it go yeah
and then it's gone already
right it's weird i love it i love it
well thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you this has been i love you
this has been a real treat really really
did you have fun yeah this is my first
podcast ever like how easy was it if you
it's never as good as this though you'll
never be as good as this again i hope
not
this is great man i appreciate i
appreciate you and i'll take you to the
magic castle [ __ ] yeah we'll go we have
to dress up you have to dress in a suit
i uh easily i would love it and we'll
laugh like kids and we'll watch magic
you want to go ryan yeah how about the
three of us go let's go just three solo
guys
and thank you for the wine looking sure
thank you for the one you brought me uh
some uh
can you do an impression of uh county
with
yeah
that's what he says
nice chianti yeah what does he say is
like
what was that line
i hate his brain i ate his liver with
some fava beans and a nice candy
yeah yeah yeah
i remember i loved that movie god he was
great was he
yeah i said someone's tried to test me
i hate his live with some fava beans and
a nice candy
it was something like there was
something like that all right dude i'll
let you go cheers brother cheers
he's got a lot a lot going on man yeah
he's busy he's busy do you want to be
that busy do you like being this busy
no
i don't know i i don't i think i lost my
wanting to be busy i think when i was
younger i just wanted to constantly be
busy and now i like time to nap
i really he did a movie called no time
to die i want
plenty of time to now plenty of time
that's the sequel
if i was in a bond movie plenty of time
to now would you see that one
uh thank you guys all for supporting the
podcast and listening again go to
patreon.com inside of you to support the
podcast and other ways to get back
uh thank you um
cumulus for supporting the podcast thank
you ryan thank you jason our editor
wonderful job jason thank you bryce for
my uh producing uh and then thanks dylan
for helping me get some guests and uh
you know right now why don't we uh
before i also before also
um la comicon i'll be there december 4th
and 5th doing a smallville nights with
tom welling he'll be here so make sure
you get your tickets and november 20th
my band sunspin is playing virtually on
stage.com but you can get tickets on
sunspin.com as well uh support the band
come see the band uh you could also go
to sunspin.com for awesome merch you see
stephen amell always wearing sunspin
hats and tom wellingworth sunspin shirts
and like uh you know i appreciate the
support it's really nice also if you
want any inside of you merch go to the
inside of you online store and there's
some great stuff um lex luthor stuff
smallville stuff uh inside of you stuff
mugs
all that all that jazz holy [ __ ] why
don't we get into the top tier patrons
these are people who give back a little
more a lot more
couldn't do the show without him
and here we go
nancy d leah s trish f sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e brian h mama lauren
uh g nico p jerry w robert b jason w
kristen k amelia o allison el raj c
joshua d emily s cjp samantha m jennifer
and stacy
l correct gen s jamal f janelle b
kimberly e mike e l don sopremo 99 more
ramirez santiago m sarah f chad w liam p
jeanine r maya p
matty s belinda n chris h i just got
into a little jack nicholson there dave
h spiderman chase sheila g
not to be confused with sheila e
brad d ray h tabitha t michelle k
michael s talia m betsy d claire baby
laura l chad l rochelle nathan e marion
meg k janelle p travl dan and lorraine g
big stevie w kendall t angel amrian and
c cory k super sam
coleman g dev nixon michelle a liz l liz
i jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator and h david c
john b brandy d yvore camille s bana
bono bono
the chief
joey m willie f christina e adelaide n
jeffrey m omar l it's it's an i right
well go back to staciel what does it say
next just acl
is that an l
yeah it's omari because you're not doing
the l yeah omari
hi omar i
omar i omari omari lena ann design otg
eugene r chris p nikki g cory and ktb
thank you podcasters thank you patrons
thank you anybody who listens to the
podcast
i really appreciate you it means a ton
to me i hope you continue to listen
we'll try to give you good interviews
and and hopefully we'll all learn
something how to be a better human being
thanks for taking the time while you're
driving to work or you're doing whatever
with your time you're spending time with
us i'm michael rosenbaum i'm ryan taylor
from the hollywood hills hills of
california ryan
big wave
a little is this what the kids are doing
uh thank you guys for listening thank
you allowing me for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you i
had a blast i hope you did too and
take care
[Music]